Clayton your nickname can't be clay I
mean I don't I don't really have a
nickname I don't think why not the
general oh well yeah I mean everybody
yeah that's that's kind of what it's
been everybody's been calling me the
general that it that is true okay how
has life changed around campus for you I
mean it's it's been insane I mean when
we when we got here I cut when I got
here a couple years ago
I mean basketball wasn't important to
anybody on campus and the way that it's
transformed this year and having
everybody talk about us everybody's
wearing their maroon and gold around
campus saying stuff to us all the time
it's been it's been crazy and it's been
really fun if I told you four months ago
you guys were going to the Final Four
you would have said what I mean I
probably I probably would have
questioned it that's for sure
I knew that we were gonna have some
pretty good pieces I mean we have a lot
of good players on our team a lot of
character guys who have won a lot in
their lives but I mean I think I'd be
lying to you if I said I was expecting
Final Four I don't think any of us
thought we would be at this point but
now that we're here I think we think
that we can kind of continue on and
maybe win a couple more games has
professor asked for an autograph yet no
professors asked for autograph they have
not but um pictures pictures i I know
one a one kid on our team said that a
professor did ask asked for a picture
but we've we've had plenty of pictures
and autographs just from like the
students on campus and stuff and it's
been it's been really fun to to kind of
experience this with all the guys on our
team alright well give me the story
about taking a picture that people
didn't know that you were on the team I
mean it's not like it's not like that's
the first time somebody didn't think I
look like a basketball player but um I
mean basically we were we were going
through the hotel and there so at our
hotel in Atlanta there was like this
FBLA thing going on there all these high
school kids like Future Business Leaders
I guess of America and the elevators
were crazy like you it would you would
have to wait like 15-20 minutes just to
get on an elevator to go up to our room
so the hotel people were escorting us to
these like other elevators that we could
use whenever we would get back from
practice or shoot around or whatever and
we were about to get we were waiting for
this elevator and there was this little
like highschool girl I guess and she
came up and she was like oh my god like
can i I want to get a picture with the
team I can I take a picture with you
guys and then she like I was like kind
of next to her on her side and she like
looked at me and goes sir like mister
like will you take the picture of me and
the team and I was like I was like I was
I was actually gonna do it I was
actually like being polite I was like
I'll take a picture you guys but then
all my teammates heard what she said and
so they were all like oh my gosh that's
doing like I mean it was funny we got a
we got a good laugh out of it sure well
maybe Michigan will forget that you're
out there though Clayton and you can
make them pay you can be anonymous when
you get out there I hope I hope that
that's the deal I hope that they they
forget forget about me and hopefully
hopefully make make some play give me
your official height in weight I'm like
I think I'm listed at 6 1 I'm probably 6
foot 6 6 foot 1 180 Wow
you don't want to mess with that do you
Clayton but growing up in you were you
grew up in Iowa right no I grew up in I
grew up in Kansas City I went to I went
to Iowa State for my freshman year but
uh okay I grew up in Overland Park
Overland Park Kansas a big Chiefs fan
Royals fan yeah huge huge Chiefs and
Royals fan did Kansas recruit you um
Candace recruited me they never actually
offered me on high school I had offers
from k-state Iowa State Oklahoma
Oklahoma State so I had like some of the
big good majority of the big 12 and then
I ended up committing the Iowa State on
high school and
okay so if I gave you a dream scenario
just hypothetical you're gonna beat
Michigan and you could either play
Villanova or Kansas for the national
title
the team that spurned you the school
that said you're not good enough to come
here General Custer I'm sorry would you
rather play Villanova or Kansas for the
national title
I mean I'd want to play you for sure
okay it's the right hand I I've been I
mean it for to get to play them in the
national championship and had a chance
to compete against then obviously we
like all all my bunch of my friends go
to Kay you and stuff too and I mean it
would just be a crazy crazy thing and
they would obviously be pretty cool
pretty cool to beat them but um I don't
know yeah I mean it it would be awesome
to play Kansas for sure ah
can you explain sister Jean like this
phenomenon here yeah
sister Jean is amazing I mean she she
she she's the type of person when you
when you walk in the room she she lights
it up she makes you feel more
comfortable and better about what's
going on she she dessert I'm glad that
the nation's starting to get to know her
because we've kind of all known how
special she is for a long time and we're
glad that everybody's starting to see
that now because she's really an
inspiration to a lot of us and for her
to be doing what she's doing it at age
98 is incredible yeah yeah
did she ever shoot around with you guys
no I've never seen her shoot shoot
baskets but I'm sure I'm sure she tried
to probably make some stuff your junior
right yeah I'm a retro junior okay if
you declare for the draft
you can come on their show if you'd like
and then you know we could have a press
conference and have you tell people
you're going pro you're not leaving
after this year right no okay okay no no
no no it's not breaking news No
he's staying he's staying he's not he's
not going it's not breaking news how
does yeah no no Clayton General Custer
is istic Fritzi what do you what do you
have here with a new nickname for him we
got a new nickname from our friend two's
in the back but he gave this over to me
so I'm gonna take it
bracket Buster Clayton Custer ooh there
we go I like that one I like that one
Clayton bracket Buster Custer here you
go
I like it oh it's a little wordy but
it's okay it doesn't exactly roll off
the tongue during the highlights how
many threes can i pencil you in for on
Saturday against Michigan just so I get
an idea here let me write that I don't
know I mean I didn't make I didn't make
a whole lot against Kansas State so
hopefully I think I think I think if the
I think if the percentages if my
percentages hold true I should I should
be good for at least a few on Saturday
all right don't be afraid to pass the
ball either Clayton okay I'm never
afraid of passable and I like that hey
congrats a lot of fun for you and good
luck against Michigan hey thank you so
much for having me on that's a Clayton
bracket Buster cluster for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]